pilot the Bombadil
pilot to Bombardier
you
it's a beautiful [ __ ] day to be
alive it's cloudy hazy these are the
best [ __ ] days to go out there
cuz everybody's walking around
look at the color [ __ ] do you mean why
you look like the clouds on big box it's
Monday June 6 you bad [ __ ]
uncle Joey here where the [ __ ] you've
been uncle driving busy alright
I think that time to be smoking a [ __ ]
dope you [ __ ] all week and you're
on your own on the weekends during the
week I'm here for the Daily Inspiration
I'm here for flock didn't you know
whatever I don't [ __ ] even know why
I'm here what I do know is clouds
[ __ ] and it's one thing anything you
needed a [ __ ] cloud it's today I used
a real [ __ ] Lord's Day for savages
yes they you relax you go to church you
shake your hands and some [ __ ]
peasants but on Monday it's time to
[ __ ] kill its attack [ __ ] so
I'm here with the [ __ ] I'm free for the
week I still got some of this perennial
towel left but I got this [ __ ] depth
on two legs this presidential and let
it's soaked on the Sun all day [ __ ]
saddle in half a day Sunday
percolate [ __ ] I got a bag of stars
it's gonna be a good [ __ ] week the
podcast tonight 8 o'clock Marc Maron
we're gonna blow up [ __ ] Wednesday
night I'm on merit Wednesday night feed
[ __ ] don't know now you know
but Joey enough with the killer chatter
let's [ __ ] spark this [ __ ] you
understand
that's all mondays are about it's you
and me against the [ __ ] world look
you wouldn't make me a new and [ __ ]
number were against the world
don't worry I've been keeping my eyes
open for that [ __ ] Mormon [ __ ] who
stole myself cockeyed [ __ ] who's got
my [ __ ] pipe I'm on the lookout for
those [ __ ] I got signs all around
town did you see this [ __ ] Piper wait
till I get my hands on those three
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you need to
worry about [ __ ] stone to the guilty
i'm sending smoke signals to [ __ ]
martians you understand it'll send smoke
signals the [ __ ] Martians uncle Joey
does you [ __ ] yet I like much today got
a couple of meetings I'm not sure budget
troop is one of the meetings coincides
with the [ __ ] thing so I hate doing
something a gun go ahead you can't
[ __ ] focus don't I be that the
podcast big week I'm all [ __ ]
the brass the Friday
Marren Wednesday night what the [ __ ]
have you done this last [ __ ] day
oh yeah oh yeah this is it baby
everybody's looking for the [ __ ]
answer this is the answer
you take three four hits of this [ __ ]
pollutes and you go out there you don't
even know how to log you don't need no
[ __ ] lie actually Rob this boy in it
is a pipe some weed and your uncle Joey
[ __ ] right here over the transmitter
don't cost you a [ __ ] dime just to
get you out of the house like a [ __ ]
Sam's listening it that thinking about
[ __ ] with you they better wake up and
apologize you ain't [ __ ] around today
tell his monday why everybody else is
talking about that week and you look at
the [ __ ] back the boys in person you
don't give a [ __ ] you're taking it to
the murky waters or the underworld and
just in case you don't know we got a
submarine [ __ ] would take it big
on Mondays I don't [ __ ] around on
Mondays people get that [ __ ] office
is there any emails from me back soon as
they open up the computers and [ __ ]
picture me with a bikini in a big dick
and a lollipop what
don't let [ __ ] breathe and
that's it basically meant you're alive
you're kicking what the [ __ ] did you got
to be sad about get up it's Monday
[ __ ] I don't know about God or
Mohammed or what the [ __ ] all I know is
it's [ __ ] Monday and your pockets are
[ __ ] empty you got to get up and get
the [ __ ] out there in exam I don't know
what you're thinking I've been there
many a [ __ ] times why how'd it get up
a little [ __ ] bodega ain't gonna
[ __ ] but it roll the [ __ ] you or
me on just to make it that they start
I'll pour you and you're gonna get a
[ __ ] you and a buttered roll on me on
that's right but then you go out then
whatever happens happens you got a scale
of building you got a hold a [ __ ] it
[ __ ] gunpoint with a [ __ ] scissor
whatever what I say [ __ ] they were
these [ __ ] cops
I don't know advocate crimes against
women plan but beside that that's it
until this week
okay people we serve enjoy if you want
smothered joining matter listen at the
two o'clock you're wasting your time I
don't even get it
like two o'clock I'm so [ __ ] jizz dub
I don't even know what the [ __ ]
happened people talk to me
I just yes in the donut I talk to it
that's your [ __ ] that's your homework
assignment for a week you don't know
nothing you don't want to know nothing
you don't know no I don't even know what
the [ __ ] I'm talkin to you know so me
walk put this pipe in my head you know
sometimes you get stunned but your pizza
with you you celebrating Monday
you gotta go a little deeper understand
it's just sometimes I'm dying you havin
a little [ __ ] deeper let's do one
more bowl of death am I gonna send you
off amongst the [ __ ] you know wolves
like this I gotta send you out but
[ __ ] integrity with the [ __ ]
rhythm in your heart that you want to go
out there and tell these [ __ ]
I'm here
[ __ ] he said the total I'm taking
your lunch box and I'm [ __ ] your wife
in here that's how I roll on what this
that's the attitude you that I'm taking
your lunch box and I'm [ __ ] your wife
in the airs with no spit know that not
[ __ ] what's-his-name Genghis Khan
star in the muffler
and I said that's that everybody's
looking for the [ __ ] answer the
answer is within you you got the [ __ ]
answers to your bronze not me not some
[ __ ] psychiatric not some [ __ ] the
psychic a way that Dean answers you got
the [ __ ] answers you wash your [ __ ]
you have an iced oatmeal or [ __ ]
smoothie and you go out there with
[ __ ] binoculars eyes you keep the
eyes open you don't wanna know not that
what do you think of the fight I don't
know what do you think of this whole
trunk day I don't [ __ ] know I don't
give a [ __ ] I'm worried about picking up
a half a [ __ ] Milky I'm saying I
never pick the bathroom in my life but
you better listen if you want to pick a
purple Jesus you gotta go I'm thinking
about a half a milk because they needed
scraps you know I'm just talking to you
from the thieves perspective
that's it no more [ __ ] hit me
I got stumped I hope you are too and
like I say it's a beautiful [ __ ] day
to be alive that's it
planning something I said they're all
good [ __ ] things cuz you take a look
at it's like a bird's flight oh Jesus
Christ everybody once again
gotta go I got [ __ ] to do and people to
see I'll catch you [ __ ] tonight
anything like might marry and get ready
to rock baby
stay black uncle Joey loves you boy you
get that you think about my life being
how he's up but put it copied on that
bully all right I just have my suspect
minute I love you